it is such a pleasure to talk to you the
first time I met you I was thirteen
years old and I sang at BMG which is now
Sony Music yeah and I performed for the
staff there they signed me that day but
you walked in and you asked me to sing
for you and I did and you were so
inspiring
encouraging humble gracious I will never
forget it Deborah I really I saw the
determination in your eyes I saw the you
know the hunger for wanting to be in
this business and I wanted to really
just be that encouragement for you you
know what I mean be that person that is
there to help to you know push you
forward and and be supportive well you
are definitely encouraging so I
appreciate you for that so we've seen so
much in the news and on social media
regarding black lives matter and the
protests how are you feeling right now
I'm a little um anxious I've been very
you know kind of anxious I've been you
know really cautious but at the same
time very very hopeful you know because
I know that this is a moment that we all
need we need to have these uncomfortable
conversations we need to see change and
the only way to get change is to go
through that uncomfortable place and
feeling I have to think about when my
son wants to drive when he you know is
behind the wheel by himself I have to
have those uncomfortable conversations
about what his conduct should be like
and that's the part just as a mother
that's really difficult to to process
you know I want my kids to grow up
thinking that they can be anything that
they want to be I want them to grow up
to feel like they have the opportunity
to live their full potential so the show
must be paws initiative it took place
earlier this month where people took the
social media to pause their daily feeds
to focus on elevating the voices of the
black lives matter movement so do you
feel the show must be paused
was a positive step or do you think it
helped at all I think it's exactly what
it was which was a pause you know when
we say black lives matter we're not
saying that it's only our lives that
matter we're saying that addition to you
know we should all you know really take
a pause and listen and understand each
other's perspective and understand each
other's point of view we can no longer
be tolerant of the kind of behavior
[Music]